lancé en mai 1960 le paquebot france va
s'achever ces aménagements à saint
nazaire ses deux cheminées dont la
hauteur est celle d'un immeuble de six
étages de quoi loger 50 personnes
apparaissent aujourd'hui débarrasser de
leurs échafaudages à trois semaines des
essais en mai et le 3 février le plus
long paquebot du monde vaudra vers la
mer
[Musique]
la septième fois cette année le
président de la république a fait les
honneurs de l'elysée à un chef d'état de
l'afrique d'expression française
monsieur hubert maga président de la
république du dahomey haute de la france
pour trois jours le coeur de nos deux
pays bas au même rythme avait dit à son
arrivée le président hubert maga ce sont
ces paroles qu'il a voulu traduire en se
recueillant sur la tombe du soldat
inconnu
[Musique]
et à travers cette visite du dahomey à
paris la foule des champs-elysées a pu
évoquer l'amitié d'un pays liés à la
france depuis 1895 et à qui elle a donné
voici un an l'indépendance
m
oh
le palais de chaillot a vu la rentrée
parisienne de minou drouet qui poète sd
longtemps consacré n'a pas dédaigné de
s'intéresser aux côtés de l'ambassadeur
d'italie à la nouvelle revue tout
l'univers cas baptisé catherine langeais
il faut dire que cette première
encyclopédie hebdomadaire tout en
couleurs qui s'adresse aux enfants de 8
à 15 ans réalise la noble ambition
d'instruire en distrayant
aux côtés du peintre jean gabriel
domergue promu président de jury de
robert rocca et maître henry torrès de
pierre du dans on devait retrouver minou
drouet preuve que paris est petit on
devrait aussi retrouver catherine
langeais qui a remis les palmes d'or du
roman d'espionnage 1961 à serge la forêt
avec une chèvre symbole de la
sorcellerie capelette évidemment le
titre de son livre le temps des sorciers
vallauris est devenu pour deux jours une
capitale la capitale de picasso vingt
mille amis admirateurs aux fanatiques du
pain sont tout simplement voulu lui
souhaiter un bon anniversaire avec
cantate fanfare feu d'artifice et
discours bien entendre avec
naturellement aussi une exposition
picasso il y est venu avec sa femme
jacqueline tout gentiment en blouson
noir au milieu des bousculades et des
acclamations et avec tout le monde il a
regardé ses toiles
celle d'hier et d'avant-hier et celle
d'aujourd'hui
on sait que des toiles il en a dans les
plus grands musées du monde que le
moindre tableau signé de son nom vaut
des millions on sait que sa première
exposition date de 1897 et que la gloire
de ce pain prétendants qui a passé sa
vie à désintégrer la peinture est
vieille d'au moins 40 ans on sait aussi
qu'il en a 80 aujourd'hui et qu'il est
toujours aussi jeune
et en souvenir de cette corrida qui la
peint père pain on lui en a offert une
avec dominguin qui est son ami
c'est vallauris qui a fêté son
anniversaire ou plutôt le nom d' entière
vallauris c'est à dire ces millions de
gens qui ne peuvent plus voir le monde
de la même façon depuis que picasso un
jour a commencé à peindre
le monde est il besoin de le dire vit
des temps troublés dans berlin nouvelles
tensions la police de monsieur olbrich
persistant à vouloir contrôler les
militaires alliées en civil au passage
de la ligne frontière le commandement us
a décidé de les faire accompagner en cas
de difficulté par des soldats en armes
c'est ce qui s'est passé à plusieurs
reprises et notamment pour le passage en
zone est de l'adjoint du général clay
ces vexations répétées faisant suite à
des mesures prises en dehors de tout
accord des quatre puissances occupantes
ont provoqué une tension accrue les
troupes ont été mises en état d' alerte
et de chaque côté de la frontière chars
américains et chars soviétiques se sont
fait face au point de passage de la
friedrichstrasse pendant plus de 12
heures
depuis la tension s'est relâchée les
charges ont été retirées mais le
problème de berlin demeure
[Musique]
à ciudad trouville l'eau c'est un autre
spectacle
la capitale de la république dominicaine
continue à vivre des semaines agitées à
plusieurs reprises des manifestations
d'étudiants se sont heurtés à la
réaction sans douceur de la police
gouvernementale
il apparaît malgré l' influence durable
de l'ex dictateur que la succession de
tours îlots dont l'un des fils a pris la
place est très controversée il ajoute à
cela la proximité de cuba
le nord de l'angola où s'était étendu la
rébellion anti portugaise a été ces
derniers mois le théâtre d'importantes
opérations militaires qui semblent avoir
abouti à une réoccupation total de cette
région difficile dont la brousse et la
montagne faisait un réduit idéal pour la
guérilla le dernier épisode la prise du
village de nambuangongo qui était devenu
le pc d'habitation a été le coup décisif
d'une campagne particulièrement dur les
unités portugaise on tue à lutter autant
avec les difficultés du pays et du
climat qu'avec les noyaux de robert
l'opération de pedra vers des collines
de 300 mètres d'altitude qui émerge de
la forêt tropicale devait être le point
crucial de cette avance qui a permis
d'occupation de nambuangongo laissé en
ruines par ses occupants les populations
qui avaient fui leurs foyers rentrer
maintenant peu à peu et on peut croire
que les mouvements militaires de
quelqu'un vire-vire ont pris fin mais le
leader nationaliste holden roberto qui
dirige la rébellion depuis léopoldville
ne désarment pas
au milieu de cette période trouble nous
vivons l'amélioration des techniques
militaires n'apporte pas il faut bien le
dire une très grande consolation que le
ministre de la guerre britannique
monsieur john profumo se voit présenter
un conte mobile au déploiement
automatique de la meilleure facture ne
nous emplit que d'une joie mesurée
la découverte du super charge iftn le
dernier né des usines d'armement 47
tonnes avec canon à performance tenue
secrète n'est pour personne un élément
d'enthousiastes
le confort du blessé a en tout cas fait
de sérieux progrès avec ses doubles
civière qui glisse sur un matelas d'air
comprimé il en existe d'ailleurs une
version à main pour blesser salle qui
laisse loin derrière elle tous les
brancards de naguère a longtemps dû
s'il avait été là tout petit peu
superstitieux les 13 jockey du grand
steeple de tchécoslovaquie n'aurait
peut-être pas pris le départ de
l'épreuve et il serait sans doute bien
fait je me sens la curd oeuvre les 6900
mètres du parcours sont jalonnées de
bien d'autres obstacles que l'on
franchit tant bien que mal et plutôt mal
que bien mais l'essentiel n'est-il pas
de rester sur le taux du cheval
ok
et maintenant qu'on est dans
continuez question se dérober de toute
façon le cheval n'a pas d'avis à donner
le plus étonnant c'est qu'il y a tout de
même à vainqueur à l'arrivée
[Rires]
pas question de rêver devant la beauté
du paysage ici dans ces montagnes du
canada on prépare l'avenir un avenir qui
n'est pas très rose il est vrai
ces montagnards ce sont des sauveteurs
de la gendarmerie royale canadienne qui
effectue un exercice
une nouveauté dans leur système au lieu
d'utiliser des cordages il emploie des
câbles d'acier qui mis bout à bout
peuvent atteindre près de 500 mètres de
longueur
avec ses câbles et aux moyens de poulies
on peut parfaitement descendra blessé le
long d'une paroi abrupte
bien traverser une gorge ou une crevasse
[Musique]
pour les cas graves il a même été prévu
une civière
[Musique]